>> AS HE MADE THE LONG AND
SURREAL JOURNEY INTO KYIV,
PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS NOT ON A
PLANE OPERATED BY THE U.S.
MILITARY BUT INSTEAD ON A TRAIN
RUN BY UKRAINIAN RAILWAYS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN BOARDED THE
TRAIN AT THE POLL IN UKRAINE
BORDER, THAT IS SUSTAINED
STATION WHERE MANY OF THOUSANDS
OF REFUGEES ALSO TRAVELED
THROUGH AFTER RUSSIA INVADED
UKRAINE A YEAR AGO FLEEING WITH
THEIR FAMILIES AND FOR THEIR
SAFETY FROM PUTIN'S WAR.
THE HEAD OF UKRAINE'S RAILWAY
SYSTEM HAS DUBBED THE TRIP WILL
FORCE ONE NOW SAYING IT WAS AN
HONOR TO HOST A BIDEN WHILE
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT IT WAS QUITE
A COMPLICATED JOURNEY TO GET
THE PRESIDENT ON THE PLANE AND
ALEXANDER APOLOGIZED FOR THE
FRACKING RAILWAY ON TIME
PERFORMANCE SAYING STILL 90% OF
THE TRAIN ON THAT SECRET TRIP
AS IT WAS GOING ON DID OPERATE
ON TIME.
HE SAID IT WAS PAINFUL FOR ME
MY TEAM BUT I HAD TO DO THAT
POLLING 90% OF OUR TRAINS
DERIVED ON TIME YESTERDAY.
I APOLOGIZE.
I SPOKE WITH ALEXANDER JUST
BEFORE THE PROGRAM THIS
MORNING.
>> JOINING ME NOW IS THE CEO OF
UKRAINIAN RAILWAYS, ALEXANDER
COMMOTION.
ALEXANDER, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING WITH US.
WE KNOW YOU HAD QUITE A WEEK.
WHEN DID YOU FIND OUT THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS COMING
THAT'S GOING TO BE RIDING ON
ONE OF YOUR TRAINS?
>> WE WERE VERY HAPPY TO BRING
HIM IN AND OUT WITH THIS VISIT.
I'M SURE THAT WAS A HISTORICAL
MOMENT FOR UKRAINE, FOR U.S.,
FOR THE WHOLE WORLD BECAUSE IF
YOU REMEMBER, RUSSIAN PROMISED
TO TAKE IN THE --
FALL IN THE 62ND DAY OF THE WAR
PRESIDENT BIDEN WILL
[INAUDIBLE]
IT IS KIND OF A REALLY
HISTORICAL MOMENT.
WE WERE HAPPY AND PRIVILEGED
AND HONORED TO BE THE OFFICIAL
CARRIER OF THE PRESIDENT BIDEN
SO WE CALLED HOUR TRAIN RAIL
FORCE ONE.
>> [LAUGHTER]
THAT IS WHY YOU HAVE DUBBED IT
NOW THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
NEVER BEEN ON BOARD.
DO >> YES.
>> YOU TALK TO MY COLLEAGUE
ANDERSON COOPER ABOUT A YEAR
AGO WHEN YOU TOLD HIM THEN THAT
YOU ARE READY TO HOST PRESIDENT
BIDEN IF HE WAS GOING TO COME
TO UKRAINE.
YOU ARE READY FOR HIM TO TRAVEL
TO ONE OF YOUR CARDS.
WHEN YOU FOUND OUT HE WAS
ACTUALLY COMING, WHERE YOU KIND
OF NERVOUS?
>> I WAS NOT NERVOUS BUT
FOCUSED AND DETERMINED UNTIL
THE MOMENT HE LEFT THE BORDER
OF UKRAINE BECAUSE TRUST ME IT
WAS A COMPLICATED MISSION AND
WE GOT A PRETTY MUCH A BIG JOB
TO DO TO MAKE IT HAPPEN IN A
PROPER WAY AND WE HAVE DONE IT.
>> WHAT KIND OF PREPARATION
GOES INTO THAT?
HOW DO YOU PREPARE TO HOST A
U.S. PRESIDENT IN SUCH A
DANGEROUS TIME AND DANGEROUS
PLACE?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
WE WANT TO HAND IN HAND WITH
THE EMBASSY OF U.S., UKRAINE
WALKED HAND-IN-HAND WITH OTHER
SPECIAL SERVICES FROM U.S., AND
FROM UKRAINIAN SIDE, DID MR.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF UKRAINE
AND FINALLY WE GOT THE JOB
DONE.
>> YOU ALSO HOSTED OTHER WORLD
LEADERS, EVERY WORLD LEADER
THAT HAS COME TO UKRAINE HAS
TRAVELED ON ONE OF YOUR TRAINS
GETTING INTO KYIV.
WHAT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY LIKE
TO HAVE PEOPLE LIKE THAT ON
YOUR TRAINS?
>> WE GOT ABOUT 300 OFFICIAL
DELEGATIONS WITH WORLDWIDE
LEADERS, PRESIDENTS, PRIME
MINISTERS, MEMBERS OF
PARLIAMENT, OF THE CONGRESS AND
IT'S REALLY RESPONSIBLE MISSION
FOR US.
WE CALL THIS MISSION IRON
DIPLOMACY.
THAT IS HOW WE HELP OUR
PRESIDENT TO MAKE HIS
DIPLOMATIC MISSION HAPPEN.
EVERY SINGLE GUEST OF IRON
DIPLOMACY PROGRAM IS A HONORED
GUEST FOR US.
WE DO OUR BEST TO BRING THEM IN
AND OUT SAFELY.
THAT IS FIRST OF ALL.
SECOND, WE TRY TO SHOW THEM
WHAT IS UKRAINE BECAUSE THEY
USUALLY SPEND, ON THE TRAIN,
MUCH MORE TIME THAN ON THE CITY
AND THAT WAS THE SAME THING
WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN AS WELL.
HE SPENT 20 HOURS ON THE TRAIN
AND ONLY FOUR HOURS IN THE
CITY.
WE TRY TO DO OUR BEST TO MAKE
THEIR TRIP UNFORGETTABLE.
>> IT IS QUITE A TRIP.
IT'S 20 HOURS WITH BOTH WAYS
INCLUDED.
RUSSIA --
THE RUSSIANS HAVE STRUCK THE
TRAINS BEFORE THE TRAIN TRACKS,
ARE YOU EVER WORRIED ABOUT
RETALIATION WHEN SOMETHING LIKE
THIS HAPPENS?
>> WE ARE [INAUDIBLE]
THEY TELL US DAILY SO WE KIND
OF KNOW WHAT TO DO NOW AND WE
ARE READY FOR THAT.
WE ALWAYS FIX, ALWAYS GET BACK
TO OPERATIONS.
WE NEVER, STOP NEVER CANCEL ANY
SINGLE TRAIN.
>> ONE MOST REMARKABLE THINGS
YOU SAID YESTERDAY WHEN YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE COMPLICATED
PROCESS OF GETTING BIDEN INTO
KYIV ON ONE OF YOUR TRAINS WAS
YOU APOLOGIZED TO OTHER PEOPLE
TO TAKE UKRAINIAN RAILWAYS
SAYING THAT ONLY 90% OF THE
TRAINS WERE ON TIME YESTERDAY.
I THINK EVERY ONE COULD GIVE
YOU A PASS FOR THIS ONE GIVEN
YOU WERE ACCOMMODATING THE U.S.
PRESIDENT ON SUCH A SECRET
VISIT.
>> FOR US ON TIME PERFORMANCE,
IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOCUS.
DURING THE WAR, PEOPLE SHOULD
RELY ON SOMETHING.
WE ALWAYS BECAME A RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION FOR OUR PEOPLE
AND THAT IS WHY WE HAD TO DELAY
SOME TRAINS TO MAKE THE RAIL
FORCE ONE RUN SMOOTHLY AND
SAFELY.
I HAD TO APOLOGIZE BECAUSE WE
USUALLY STRIVE TO BE AT A
BETTER PERFORMANCE BUT TWO DAYS
AGO, IT WAS NOT GOOD.
>> THE WAR HAS HAD SUCH AN
IMPACT ON YOU, PERSONALLY.
YOU HAVE BEEN TRYING TO KEEP
THE TRAINS RUNNING AS YOU WERE
NOTING AS A SOURCE OF
TRANSPORTATION FOR MANY
UKRAINIANS, YOU DID IT TO YOUR
FAMILY WAS AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE WAR.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
LOOK >> [INAUDIBLE]
I HAVE A PERSONAL IMPACT AND
LIKE MANY UKRAINIANS, THAT IS
REALLY SIGNIFICANT AND A HIGH
PRICE WE ARE PAYING IN THIS WAR.
WE ARE MISSING OUR FAMILIES AND
HAVING A FIGHT IN THIS WAR.
FINALLY, I AM SURE THAT ONE DAY
WE WILL MAKE THIS VICTORY DAY